in the beginning there was nothing so
the world was gray and lifeless but then
there was the first flame which brought
warmth life and light but these things
cannot exist alone so there was also a
disparity cold death and dark humans
were born from the dark but we are drawn
towards the light
we are warmed by fire but this fire we
cannot touch feather as his fascination
with fire persists and to hold it in
their own hand pyromancy is born from
the saturation of fire but you must
remember one thing always fear the flame
lets to be devoured by it and lose
yourself I would hate to see that happen
again
[Music]
it is the nature of fire to fade until
only dark remains but what if another
flame was born it could be a replica of
the first to ward off the darkness the
witch of izalith was one of Lord Gwyn's
last hopes if she could replicate the
first flame then the God's power would
never fade it would have been better if
she had never tried hmm I have a favor
to ask my mother the witch of izalith
was one of the primeval lords her power
came from the soul that she found near
the first flame she focused this power
to light a flame of her own but she
failed to control it
the flame of chaos engulfed mother and
my sisters and molded them into deformed
creatures the molten giant watches over
the flame of chaos our fair lady and
Mistress Queen I fled from the ruins I
do not know the details
I attempted to create the first flame
something went wrong she created a bed
of life which would become the source of
all demons there were originally seven
daughters of chaos the witch and two
sisters were bound to the bed of chaos
the witch is trapped inside that her two
sisters became the orbs decider Quelaag
and the fair lady were bound to giant
spiders one sister was corrupted and
guards her mother another sister was
sacrificed and is watched by her brother
who became a being of ceaseless
discharge only quelana remains and now
i'm here but my mother and sisters have
been in anguish since I beseech you free
mother and my sisters from the flame of
chaos I cannot do it myself I lack the
strength and the bravery but you I
realize what I am asking
but please free their poor souls quell
ugh the deformed daughter of izalith she
escaped with her sister and they
fashioned a home at the base of black
town the denizens of Blighttown were
chosen as servants and food
but the fair lady felt for the suffering
of her disfigured followers and sucked
out there blight bus she poisoned
herself and so the fair lady started to
die but at least she has her sister
quelaag
quelaag kills everyone who enter solo to
gather the humanity that heals her dying
sister that is until she is killed by
the chosen Undead
so who will take care of her
now that our sister has gone dark Wraith
Kirke night of thorns has tricked dark
stork akov out of a red eye orb he
invades worlds to steal humanity to heal
the fair lady
rather than give them to cough his
actions reveal that not all dark wraiths
are evil however he is ultimately killed
by the chosen undead as his intentions
are not understood until his corpse is
found in the fair lady's company time in
Lordran is convoluted 100 may replace
quelaag of guilt
may choose to put the veil ad out of a
misery
[Music]
[Music]